you know i used to open for john lovitz
and then did i tell you this story
no i didn't so i used to open for john
lovitz at the laugh factory and
this is when i'm cleaning yachts and
selling shoes at nordstrom rack
i remember i was going to nordstrom rack
and i look at my phone it's just a
number and it's
and i answered and it's like hi it's
john levitt and i'm freaking out because
i used to impersonate him in school
you know what i mean the liar and all
that stuff you know all those jokes yeah
yeah and then uh and then here he is
actually on my phone he's like i i
really i've been watching you at the
laugh factory and
i really want you to open for me you'd
be hysterical
i'm doing a show i'll do the show every
wednesday night
love it's wednesdays or some [ __ ] i
don't know love it or not
or something i'm trying to make [ __ ] up
and then uh so i was like yeah and i
started doing these shows with them
and next you know this is a true story
you're gonna love this this is such a
[ __ ]
weird thing you ready nick i don't know
if i told you this story but he goes
he goes i'm gonna i'm gonna start
this is so funny i'm gonna start putting
this uh
lady on the show her name is chelsea
handler
she's so funny she's my only friend on
myspace
what the [ __ ] he goes when you go home
go to your myspace she's my only friend
her and tom and i went home and it was
literally
tom and her and that's when i found out
who chelsea was and she started doing
these shows
and after every show she would she would
talk so much [ __ ]
so while john's on stage she's just
talking [ __ ] and then she was like
i want you to be my sidekick i got this
show idea and we're pitching the show
and uh and i want you to be my sidekick
and so i was
pretty much supposed to be chewy wow
yeah
and and then uh and then i turned it
down but we went through all kinds of
like
you know like like meetings they weren't
like full-on production meetings but it
was like
ideas and going through the meetings and
getting ready for the pitch and then
finally i was just like uh
i go hey chelsea i called her on the
phone i was like yeah i just
i really want to be my guy like i don't
want to be a sidekick i'm trying to find
this i want to do my own special i want
to blah blah and she cursed me out bro
damn she's like oh good luck with that
[ __ ] [ __ ] watch this brother and she
just cursing me out
she's like this show is gonna be a
[ __ ] hit you made the wrong [ __ ]
decision and then she hangs up the phone
i'm just like
huh and six months later chelsea
lately is just blowing up wow and i'm at
nordstrom rack
and i remember my ex-wife picking me up
and uh while she's driving me home she's
like
i'm recording this show right now we got
to get home this this lady chelsea
handler
she's so funny i've seen it and i'm like
that's the [ __ ] show i was supposed
to be on
dang and uh and i remember i was so
depressed
and uh wondering why you know why i said
no
to it and uh for six months i didn't get
a call from and then finally she called
me
but but anyways what i was getting at
like i felt i feel like i'm
always fighting to tell people i'm funny
yeah chelsea was the only one that
said yes and and and it was funny
because it was just like comedy
central's passing on me abc turned me
down
you know i got on this one pilot they
fired me and it's just like
like what is going on why don't i have
an hour yet like i don't understand why
i don't have an hour i'm crushing on the
road right now why don't i have an hour
so
yeah i feel you man i just like what is
it that you're not getting is it because
you guys don't get it because
the the country gets it right but why
aren't you guys getting it so good
evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one